it's another small step for human space
travel as blue origin prepares to launch
a six-person crew to space this morning
previous flights have had only four
people here's a live look at the new
shepard named for the late astronaut
alan shepard as it awaits the countdown
in western texas under what appears to
be a fairly blue sky for the short ride
to space and back this will be the third
human flight for jeff bezos company the
19th overall and it will cap a record
year for space flight omar villafranca
is in van horn texas this morning omar
you've got one of the best seats out
there i see it's a little chilly but i
know you've got it under control how are
you
good morning from chile west texas it's
a beautiful sunrise as we're watching
in front of me we're a few miles from
the launch pad and just over an hour
blue origin is going to be taking six
people to the edge of space as you
mentioned in the new shepard rocket and
there are some familiar names some you
may have heard of we'll start of course
with our friend at abc michael strahan
the nfl
hall of famer uh he'll be joined by
laura shepard
churchley as guests of blue origin now
shepard churchley is the daughter of
astronaut alan shepard who's the first
american in space and the namesake of
the rocket that's launching today he was
also the fifth person to walk on the
moon which is going to be pretty cool
for her to go to space
and her father famously did what no one
has ever done not even tiger woods
hit a golf ball on the moon
also flying today for paying customers
venture capitalist lean bess and his
child cameron they'll be the first
parent child duo in space which is
pretty cool dylan taylor a space
industry investor and evan dick an
engineer and an investor and they'll be
the first time the new shepherd as you
mentioned is flying a full crew
of six people now after blasting off
they'll reach about
you know a small 2 200 miles per hour in
just over two minutes and shortly after
that the crew capsule will separate
it'll continue upward and it'll cross
the 62 mile mark which is
internationally recognized edge of space
passengers then will be able to do the
unthinkable they'll unbuckle themselves
and actually experience a few minutes of
weightlessness but gravity is pretty
much undefeated what goes up must come
down they'll strap back in as the
gravity takes over before a parachute
landing just a few miles here from the
liftoff from
takeoff to landing
just over uh 10 minutes now this was
delayed uh two times two days because of
the winds here in west texas it's
beautifully calm right now so this
flight is expected to happen later on
this morning and we will have a front
row seat
jericho oh omar thank you so much that
goes into this
really incredible 13th flight as they're
considering space flight of the season
uh space mission i suppose we should say
since they hit the edge and just overall
what an exciting year it's been
yesterday's travel engine busiest since
85.
it's amazing all right